[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors l'histoire commence ainsi j'étais
à New York pour la projection d'un de
mes films étoiles l'histoire de ce
martiniquais qui devait être le premier
entier dans l'espace je préparais la
suite de la projection avec une
médiatrice un entretien avec du public
et elle m'a dit ceci elle m'a donné ce
conseil elle m'a dit commence par une
histoire drôle
alors j'ai raconté ceci j'étais à New
York pour la projection d'un de mes
films étoiles l'histoire de cet
Antillais qui devait être le premier
dans l'espace j'étais avec une
médiatrice en train de préparer la suite
de la projection un entretien avec du
public et elle m'a donné ce conseil elle
m'a dit commence par une histoire drôle
alors j'ai raconté ceci
j'étais à New York pour la projection
d'un de mes films
enfin bon vous connaissez
donc voilà l'épreuve de l'histoire drôle
est passée enfin l'épreuve pour vous
mais le ton et le sujet est là je vais
vous raconter une histoire je veux
raconter des histoires
alors c'est difficile à voir avec les
spots mais je crois que juste au dessus
de vous oui madame avec le joli brushing
je crois qu'il y en a une
bon je suis je suis c'est une question
qui a été un petit peu pas difficile
mais en tout cas j'avais du mal à
répondre à ça voilà est-ce que vous avez
remarqué que déjà qui ne se connaissent
pas une fois qu'ils ont donné leur nom
la première chose en fait qui demande
c'est qu'est-ce que tu fais comme si en
fait ce que nous faisions nous
définissait totalement alors une fois
que je vous aurais dit je suis boulanger
je suis maçon je suis carreleur je suis
ingénieur à Grenoble ou alors je suis
acteur de film x ou alors je suis
je ne sais pas moi pilote de ligne
est-ce que ça me définit totalement
bon alors là je me fais un petit peu
l'avocat du diable et non avocat du
diable c'est pas non plus mon métier je
fais un peu l'avocat du dial parce que
en fait je crois que je fais partie de
ces quelques chanceux qui estiment
qu'ils font ce qu'ils sont
bon maintenant je sais très bien qu'il
suffit pas que je dise je m'appelle
Gilles Eddy Kozak pour que les gens en
fait sachent enfin savent que les gens
sachent
voilà je suis pas prof de français ça
c'est clair
alors donc j'essaye de jouer le jeu
voilà donc je suis photographe oui mais
pas que je suis réalisateur oui mais pas
que je fais des collages oui mais pas
pas que bon matin artiste alors là j'ai
un petit peu du mal parce que voilà je
me vois vraiment pas être vraiment je
m'appelle Gilles je suis artiste je
trouve ça un petit peu trop pompeux
voilà donc j'ai fini par dire je raconte
des histoires
donc voilà j'ai dit cosaque raconter
l'histoire alors j'avais déjà un nom à
rallonge je me retrouve avec une
fonction à rallonge alors qui dit
fonction dit utilité alors j'ai pas non
plus la prétention en fait d'avoir une
utilité voilà si je suis là en fait dans
ce cercle rouge ben ça fait pas de moi
en fait un spécialiste de je ne sais
quoi je suis pas non plus en fait un
spécialiste de moi-même en fait pour
être très très honnête j'avoue que je me
nourris du regard et du retour des gens
pour apprendre un petit peu sur ce que
je ce que je fais raconte des histoires
des histoires avec des mots des
histoires avec des images des histoires
avec
des sons expliquant j'utilise les images
c'est des images qui bougent qui ne
bougent pas je raconte des histoires
avec des saveurs avec des épices enfin
ça c'est réservé à quelques proches mais
je l'espère pas de le partager un jour
avec le plus grand nombre je raconte des
histoires
on va revenir d'ailleurs en fait aux
pourquoi en fait raconte des histoires
et en quoi c'est important de raconter
en fait des histoires en fait les
paléontologistes font démarrer
l'histoire l'Histoire avec un grand H
avec la faculté de raconter des
histoires histoire avec des petits h
alors cette faculté en fait elle est née
d'un accident génétique qu'on a appelé
la révolution cognitive la révolution
cognitive en fait c'est ce qui a amené
l'émergence de nouvelles compétences
comme inventer comme se souvenir comme
apprendre et transmettre c'est ce qui a
permis la communication de gaz qui a été
nécessaire au développement de notre de
notre espèce alors cette réalité
imaginée elle a pris de plus en plus
d'importance et ce qui a amené en fait
nos ancêtres pas les Gaulois les autres
à vivre dans une double réalité la
réalité objective ici
il y a des fauteuils avec des gens sur
ces fauteuils et la réalité imaginée
peut-être que dans une salle à côté il y
a des gens avec des fauteuils sous leurs
fesses ou inversement cette réalité
imaginée et bien c'est celle des mythes
c'est celle des systèmes politiques
c'est celle des systèmes religieux c'est
celle des systèmes économiques cette
réalité imaginée c'est ce qui fait que
nous ne sommes pas gouvernés par nos
gènes cette réalité imaginée c'est la
culture dure Notre culture c'est cette
capacité à enchanter le quotidien alors
j'envoie une autre
oui derrière vous et
histoire se poursuit ainsi cette fois on
est en Martinique et à l'issue d'une de
mes expositions quelqu'un vient vers moi
il tient à partager son regard en fait
sur mon travail cinématographique et
graphique et de cette discussion
j'en ai retenu une phrase qui m'a
profondément marqué il m'a dit tu as une
écriture créole
tu as une écriture créole et ben cette
phrase je l'ai fait tout de suite mienne
parce que j'ai compris qu'en fait il ne
parlait pas géographie il me renvoyait
pas à mes racines à mes origines mais il
était question d'un état d'esprit tu as
une écriture créole voilà voilà quelque
chose que je pourrais revendiquer que je
pourrais porter haut comme un étendard
tu as une écriture créole voilà en une
phrase il avait synthétisé une démarche
qui jusqu'alors était somme toute
intuitive alors évidemment à tous ces
murs tout honneur ben moi cette phrase
ça m'a fait penser au principe au
concept de création d'Edouard Glissant
mais pour vous expliquer un petit peu
plus ça je vais avoir besoin de votre
aide
[Musique]
vous par exemple oui oui jeune homme
s'il vous plaît est-ce que vous pouvez
oui vous oui est-ce que vous pouvez me
rejoindre sur scène s'il vous plaît
merci
[Applaudissements]
alors la créalisation c'est un métissage
d'art de langage qui produit de
l'inattendu c'est un espace où la
dispersion permet de se rassembler où
les chocs de culture la dysharmonie le
désordre l'interférence devienne
créateur c'est la création d'une culture
ouverte et inestructable qui bouscule
l'uniformisation Édouard Clisson
on pourrait dire
la colonisation c'est l'art de maronner
avec les règles c'est l'art de maronner
avec les avec le cadre voilà
on pourrait dire ça par exemple
là je viens de marronner en fait une des
règles des organisateurs en fait de
cette conférence qui à savoir faire un
discours sans note mais bon je me voyais
pas marronner avec la pensée d'Edouard
Glissant
merci merci beaucoup
donc une écriture une histoire créole tu
as une écriture créole donc je raconte
des histoires pas des histoires créoles
mais je raconte des histoires de façon
créole mais voilà pour être très honnête
avec vous je raconte aussi l'histoire
créole mais je pourrais tout aussi bien
raconter des histoires japonaises de
façon créole parce que on n'est pas dans
le point GPS on est dans quelque chose
qui a pu savoir avec la sociologie de la
philosophie c'est un état d'esprit
je suis sûr que maintenant en fait vous
les chercher
mais peut-être que si vous fermez les
yeux vous les verrez mieux parfois enfin
ça aide
c'est le moment où je vous parle en fait
de la fin de l'histoire la femme
momentanée qui se déroule ben juste
avant en fait ce taux c'est le moment en
fait ou quelqu'un vienne me demander
mais
comment tu as eu cette idée voilà
comment j'ai eu cette idée ou comment
les idées viennent mais voilà une
question en fait qui revient souvent au
cours de discussion avec avec du public
comment viennent les idées comme si les
gens attendaient parfois en fait une
recette parfois c'est la saint curiosité
mais voilà c'est parfois un petit peu
ambigu comme quand vous allez chez tata
Janine et puis elle vous fait ce
magnifique gâteau au chocolat ou cette
tarte tatin au choix et puis on lui
demande mais quel est ton secret quelle
est ta recette ou alors chez le cousin
Bébert en fait qui fait une sauce chien
à tomber par terre comment fais-tu
comment je fais comment on fait
je sais pas
je sais pas parce qu'à un moment en fait
les choses se matérialisent souvent une
phrase à la suite d'un pari un homme
joue sa fille sur un combat de coq
quelqu'un va construire une fusée et
puis va la propulser avec la poésie
d'aimer ses airs ou bien je vais parler
d'un match de foot je vais faire jouer
en fait des grands joueurs de football
et puis ils auront pas de ballon ou bien
j'ai fait une installation de boîte de
conserve et sur lequel je vais mettre
des plantes bâtonnets grillées voilà un
moment en fait les choses sont là je
pense qu'en fait je suis vous êtes des
éponges voilà qui ne demandent que de
temps à autre avoir un auto essorage pas
que pas qu'on soit essoré par d'autres
personnes voilà mais c'est là où revient
en fait cette idée en fait de de
réalisation et d'écriture créole et
d'esprit créole
maintenant en fait le processus et pour
moi un petit peu plus un petit peu plus
évident parce que je crée tu crées il ou
elle créole
l'esprit créole en fait avant tout est
un pour moi en fait une démarche de
création voilà créer est une démarche
créole
parce que il est question de
d'assemblage de carambolage de
d'enfantillage de bricolage de naïveté
et de curiosité il est question en fait
de faire un pas de côté voilà c'est le
fameux pas instable le Big
alors les soubresauts et les choses
strates de l'histoire aussi douloureux
qu'ils aient pu s'être mais ont amené
l'éclosion en fait de cette formidable
culture la culture créole il y a je
pense dans la culture créole et quand je
parle de culture en fait il ne s'agit
pas en fait d'art il y a en fait dans la
culture créole tous les outils et les
références nécessaires pour apporter
d'autres réponses au monde pour répondre
à porter une réponse des réponses
différentes et ça dans tous les domaines
alors moi à mon petit niveau et ben je
raconte des histoires pour promouvoir
cette idée
si vous demandiez en fait
à quoi il fallait faire attention
pendant ces 10 minutes
et ben en fait c'était les suites de
l'histoire et les suites de l'histoire
en fait elles sont par là elles sont
nombreuses il y en a tout autant que de
spectateurs dans cette salle ou de
spectateurs qui verront en fait ce truc
plus tard
à vous de les saisir voilà et j'aimerais
vraiment beaucoup mais que vous me les
racontiez je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]